I think the pleasure,
funnily enough of the greatest pleasure
of writing comes from the response you
get from the readers.
Here I am in New York.
You walk down the street,
people stop and talk to you and say how
much they love the book and the sort of
praise and uh,
there's been coming in for the,
for the latest book is very touching,
so it's damned hard work.
Of course,
I meant let's get ourselves,
you,
it's,
it's not an easy job being a writer,
but once it's finished and you've done
it and it's published and it's in the
shops and if you're lucky,
it goes on the best seller's list.
That's very exciting indeed.
I don't find that a struggle because I
spent a year
before I sit down to write on the first
day and then I go away and have a very
disciplined routine.
I rise at five in the morning and I
start work at six.
I work from six until eight from 10
until 12 from two until four from six
until eight.
I've got to bed about nine 30 10 having
a light supper and then I'll get up
again at five the next morning.
And there's 50 days of that is the
beginning of what you call the struggle
and that it's tough work.
And that's probably three or 400 hours.
And then I take a break and then I will
go back to it.
And the last draft of a prisoner of
birth,
my latest book was probably the 16th or
17th drops before anybody read it.
Great processors.
Not
easy to describe because it's a bit like
if you're a violinist or if you're a
painter.
I'm a storyteller.
So this is happening all the time.
My mind is buzzing off in different
directions all the time.
But I don't sit down and write a book
until I've had a year of thinking about
an idea and taking it through.
So the idea in a prisoner of birth is
the story of a young man born in the
east end of London,
the poor part of London,
who takes his girlfriend to the west end
to ask her to marry him,
and he gets involved in a fight,
nothing to do with him,
and he's arrested for murder and he then
you see the trial and he's condemned for
murder and sent to a prison from where
no one has escaped.
But he does escape.
He gets out and he seeks revenge on the
four people who put him there in the
first place.
Of course,
I see it clearly as an updating of the
count of Monte Cristo and the genius of
Dumas's book was the way the prisoner
got out and the way he raised the money
or add the money to gain revenge on the
four people.
So even before I sat down to write,
I made the decision,
I must know how Danny can't rate gets
out of prison.
the money that will make it possible for
him to succeed.
Trust.
I've had problems where I've got to a
point and I can't see a way out of it,
but I've never,
I've never actually sat down and
thought,
oh,
I don't know what to do next.
And they were never,
well,
on that particular occasion,
it arose in a book I wrote called as the
crow flies where I had an Australian.
I'd had to have a man flight to
Australia to solve the mystery of how he
would inherit the fortune.
And when he got there,
the person who was going to solve it had
died a few weeks before he arrived.
That was suddenly thrown on me when I
went to bed that night,
and I didn't have the answer when I woke
the next morning.
So I walked around a golf course for
three days on and on and on until
suddenly in a split second,
it broke.
And it was so simple as all good ideas
are that got me off the hook.